just just one talk this morning
by amin oglum um he
is um let me see he's
worked extensively in random ksat and
random graphs
and statistical physics
and uh he asked if you oh i should
do a little bit of housekeeping here if
you want to
ask any questions please type them into
the chat window or the q a window
if you're an attendee and want to be
upgraded to a
panelist just raise your hand and uh
oh oh meet or i can uh
can up can can upgrade you if you have
questions during the talk again put them
in the chat window
possibly i'll interrupt mean and
otherwise we'll save the questions for
the end of the
talk and without further ado
let's get started i mean speaking about
belief and survey propagation
thank you um yes so in this talk i would
like to
share some um ideas about random k-set
and in particular i'm going to present
some
um algorithms that stirred quite a bit
of excitement about
20 years ago and that are rooted in
ideas
from statistical physics so for the
experts in the audience this
might all be um
well well-known stuff but i was kind of
laboring under the assumption that most
of the audience are not experts on
random satisfiability so
i'm going to give a bit of a survey on
these ideas from
statistical physics there's quite a lot
of material and if i don't get through
everything maybe it's not the end of the
world
um so just let me know that i'm going to
quickly or too slowly and
i will be happy to to accommodate
everybody
okay so about 20 years ago this picture
here
caused quite a bit of excitement here
you see
the performance of various algorithms on
randomly generated
four set instances so these are random
satisfiability instances with clauses
comprising four literals and
m is the number of clauses n is the
number of
variables and the key parameter in
random satisfiability is the clause to
variable ratio so how many
more or how many fewer clauses we have
than
variables and
in this picture you see on the x-axis
this clause to variable density
as a parameter and these bars here
indicate up to what point various types
of
satisfiability algorithms succeed
z chef was a well-known set solver at
the time
i understand and s e b
is stands for shortest clause with
backtracking
and this was the best rigorously
analyzed algorithm on random
satisfiability instances
at the time and these three bars down
here
are new algorithms that were proposed in
this
paper by mizar parisi and zikina three
physicists
um and these were all experimental
results so they
tried out their algorithms on randomly
generated
satisfiability instances and as it
turned out
these new algorithms in particular
survey propagation this last algorithm
here
outperformed the existing algorithms
that have
been developed in the combinatorics and
computer science communities rather
significantly so at the time this was
like
our first nightmare coming true there
was this problem that that we
thought may be computationally difficult
or challenging
or intractable or something like that
at the time we didn't have good
algorithms and then
physicists come in comes along and
proposes a
better algorithm so that was quite a
shock at the time
and so in this talk i would like to
discuss how these algorithms are
supposed to work believe in survey
propagation
what the ideas behind these algorithms
are and what we know about them
mathematically at this point
so let me first talk a bit about random
casert in general the distinct feature
of random satisfiability
is that there is a satisfiability phase
transition
so if you fix any clause length like for
example three or four
and you uh take a number of boolean
variables some
n boolean variables and now you add
random clauses
one by one then obviously what happens
is that
the probability that you can satisfy all
the clauses simultaneously
drops as you add more and more clauses
but in random satisfiability it turns
out that this drop
in probability that this the probability
that you can satisfy all the clauses
that this probability it does not drop
uniformly or linearly or anything like
that
but turns out that there is a sharp
threshold where suddenly the probability
that all the clauses can be satisfied
drops from one to zero so there's
a sudden drop at a particular threshold
that depends on the number of literals
in each clause
and you can try and run experiments to
pinpoint or at least
approximately see where this drop occurs
and this point
is what has been called the
satisfiability
threshold at first this was pointed out
experimentally
and subsequently quite a bit of research
on the mathematical side has been
devoted to this question
and in a very important paper in 1999
fried good proved
the existence of a
threshold for satisfiability of this
point where suddenly the probability
drops
based on non-constructive arguments so
his
result his proof is a pure existence
result it doesn't actually tell you
what the value of this threshold is but
it shows that
there exists such a sharp drop from one
to zero
at a certain point a bit earlier even
than that
two independent articles one by quartile
and read and one by gerd
actually solved the problem in the
special case that your clauses have
size two that there's two literals per
clause of course that's a very
special case because the two-side
problem can be solved in polynomial time
and the paper these proofs use
percolation like
ideas so kind of classical combinatorial
arguments but a big question at the time
was
what is the location of the
satisfiability threshold what are the
combinatorial phenomena
that cause this peculiar behavior and
also can we actually algorithmically
solve
random satisfiability instances and then
came what i would call the dark ages
so in the beginning after this problem
was kind of discovered in the early 90s
people didn't really know what to do and
there were a few simple ideas and
techniques out there that people
try to apply like for example the first
moment method
the idea behind the first moment method
is that we want to get
an upper bound on this particular value
on the satisfiability threshold here so
we want to know
approximately where its location is and
we for the beginning using the first
moment method
are attempting to derive an upper bound
so we've got n variables and clauses
and to get an upper bound what we could
do a very simple idea would be to
calculate the
expected number of satisfying
assignments
so that is my number of satisfying
assignments and using the linearity of
expectation i could simply
write this inequality here the
expectation of that is upper bounded by
2 to the n
times 1 minus 2 to the minus k to the m
where does this bound come from well two
to the n
is the number of possible truth
assignments of n
variables and in the random case that
problem my clauses are independent so
the probability that all of them
are satisfied by a particular assignment
is the probability that one single
random clause
will be satisfied to the power of m the
number of clauses
and the probability that one particular
truth assignment happens to satisfy one
randomly
chosen clause is one minus two to the
minus k
because out of the two to the k possible
ways of
choosing the signs of the literals
exactly
one fails to be satisfied by
a specific truth assignment
and clearly if the expected number of
satisfying assignments is less than 1 if
that
number goes to 0 then
markov's inequality will tell us that
our random formula doesn't
have a satisfying assignment typically
and
doing the algebra we get this upper
bound here on the satisfiability
threshold the satisfiability threshold
will be upper bounded by
log 2 on minus log 1 minus 2 to the
minus k which is approximately
2 to the k times log 2.
so this was um yeah folklore simple
um calculation that you could do and
also the other
i mean just just to give you an idea in
random two set
the actual threshold happens to be the
clause variable ratio one so
once you have more clauses than
variables your formula is not going to
be satisfiable anymore
if you use um the first moment bound you
get
a fairly crude upper bound you get
something like 2.41
which is way bigger than the actual
threshold
but be that as it may
so how about lower bounds on the
satisfiability threshold how about
actually finding satisfying assignments
well people looked into
the analysis of various simple
algorithms for
finding satisfying assignments like the
pure literal rule or unit clause
or shortest clause and over time
people discovered that there's one
method that
is very good at analyzing these
algorithms called the method of
differential equations largely pioneered
by nick walmart
and in the context of satisfiability by
demetrius acleopters
here you see the differential equations
that you can use in order to analyze the
unit clause propagation
algorithm for random reset and
what these results what these analysis
gave was that
your random satisfy your random set
formula
is going to have a satisfying assignment
if
the clause variable density so the
number of clauses divided by the number
of variables
is less than about 1.8
times 2 to the k on k remember that the
first moment upper bound
gave us a bound of two to the k times
log two
so there's somehow this factor of k here
um
that that remains as a gap so
the gap between the algorithmic lower
bound and the first moment bound is
about
a factor of k um
right so this was the state of the art
at the turn of the millennium
and we were kind of stuck on this we
didn't really
have very good idea what to do how to
proceed
but then came our very good friends from
physics to the rescue
and so maybe it might
appear peculiar that a bunch of
statistical physicists should suddenly
look into the random satisfiability
problem i mean
why should they and it turns out
that from a combinatorial viewpoint
actually the random satisfiability
problem is quite closely
related to a problem in statistical
physics called
the spin glass problem now for all i
know this might be
a bit of an obscure topic in statistical
physics
and it certainly is it's probably for
all i know not center stage in
statistical physics
it's a problem about the magnetic
properties of alloys like for example if
you take an alloy of
gold and iron then this turns out to
have some very peculiar magnetic
properties and the statistical
physicists attempted to understand
what's happening with these alloys
and one group in particular a group
around
parisi attempt or parisian visa really
attempted uh or put forward a hypothesis
of what's actually happening in these
alloys and what might unlock the spin
glass problem and this was the idea of
replica symmetry breaking
and once this idea was discovered
it emerged that quite a lot of problems
in combinatorics actually look very much
like spin glasses if you take a closer
look
you you discover some similar features
in many combinatorial problems including
and particularly
random satisfiability now of course in
statistical physics
people were interested mostly in
heuristic arguments and
in ideas i mean physicists are wonderous
people they are actually interested in
reality
uh which is something that that for a
mathematician is a very
rare um constellation
and so in particular these physics
arguments were heuristic they didn't
come with mathematical proofs
but nonetheless they were inspirational
and turned out to actually lead to very
interesting mathematical
discoveries um so here's the idea of
replica symmetry breaking the idea in
the context of satisfiability was to say
well we need to look not just
at whether our formula has a satisfying
assignment or not
but we also need to inspect how these um
satisfy
satisfying assignments are structured
how they are
located relative to one another and what
the structure of the entire set of
satisfying assignments is a bit like
linear algebra really where you
kind of understand the problem really
only once you
understand things like linear
independence and bases
and and subspaces and the kernel and so
on
and so that's what our good friends from
physicists from physics
advised us to look into and um
the hypothesis the physics prediction
was that up to a certain clause to
variable density of about 2 to the k
log k on k so again almost a factor k
below the satisfiability threshold the
satisfiability problem the random
satisfiability problem is shaped purely
by
local effects so if you want to
construct a
satisfying assignment pretty much the
only thing you have to pay attention to
is local correlations so you may have to
look at a variable and the clauses
that that variable appears in and the
variable that
the variables that appear in those
clauses and the
clauses that contain those variables
again up to a few levels maybe
but once you get the local structure
right once you get
on top of the local structure you're
good there's no
funny long range effects no complicated
long-distance phenomena going on um up
to this clause variable density your set
of satisfying assignments are shaped
purely by local phenomena and therefore
simple algorithms like for example
simulated annealing
or maybe even roxat should be able to
solve satisfiability instances
random satisfiability instances of these
densities
and then something interesting happens
namely
there's a phase transition that affects
the
geometry of the space of solutions so
this is not the satisfiability phase
transition
before and after this particular density
of 2 to the k log k on k we are going to
have satisfying assignments
but what happens is that at this point
the shape
of the set of satisfying assignments has
been predicted
to change and
at this point this kind of contiguous
set of satisfying assignments suddenly
decomposes into
many well-separated clusters
and apart from these clusters also local
minima develop that are going to trap
or that are predicted to trap local
search algorithms such as simulated
annealing
and so this decomposition into clusters
um also has a particular structure
namely these clusters i mean um
are kind of that they they admit a nice
combinatorial description
namely you can define these clusters
kind of like
subspaces in a vector space namely these
clusters
are they can be described by zero one
star
assignments so for each variable you
have one of three possible values now
zero one or star
zero means that in all these satisfying
assignments in this cluster and this
cluster here for example
this variable will always take the value
false what means that in all these
satisfying assignments in this
cluster here on this little island the
variable is always going to take the
value
true and star means that it's undecided
in some of the assignments here
the variable can take the value too and
others it can take
the value false and um
so these these encodings these zero one
star encodings
uh effectively describe the cluster
structure and
um yeah so so there's kind of
a uh so apart from the satisfying
assignments themselves there's kind of
this this structure that explains
how they are located how they are how
they uh
are spaced to one another
even though we have this clustered
structure
it turns out that the cluster volumes
are very small in this entire phase
so the class each cluster itself
is small by comparison to the entire set
of satisfying assignments
and as a result we still have some kind
of
a correlation decay property we still
don't really have extreme extensive
long-range correlations
so specifically if you look at two
variables that are par
far apart from one another in in this in
in the graph that
describes how variables appear in
clauses
then variables that are part are still
going to be essentially independent
meaning that if you look at two
variables that are far apart like for
example variable number one and variable
number two
and you look at the probability let's
say that both these variables are set to
true under a random
solution to your problem under a random
satisfying assignment
to your formula then um what we expect
in this regime
is that these events are independent so
the probability that
x1 and x2 are both set to true is
um factor prices it's the probability
that the first variable is set to
two choose times the probability that
the second variable
is set to true so despite this cluster
geometry we don't really have
um long-range correlations that
if once i tell you the value of one
variable you suddenly can
learn a lot about the values of many
other variables that are
very far away from your first variable
that changes at another phase transition
point
the so-called condensation phase
transition point where
suddenly these extensive long-range
correlations
start to appear prevail
this phase transition is expected to
appear very briefly just
within a whisker of the satisfiability
threshold itself
and what happens at this point is that
the very largest cluster
in your in your set of satisfying
assignments
are about the same yes exactly so by
distance between variables i mean the
distance in this bipartite variable
clause is
incidence graph precisely right so what
happens is that
suddenly the the largest clusters have a
volume that is about the same
as the volume of the entire set of
satisfying assignments
so um and now if i tell you um
i just observed variable x1 and it has
the value true
then that might give you a hint that
maybe i'm in this big cluster here not
in that one
so given that x1 is set to too true
maybe
with very high probability i'm looking
at a satisfying assignment in this
cluster and not at that cluster
and therefore suddenly maybe you might
get a clue
what value x2 might take because maybe
x2 is frozen or maybe
x2 has a very biased
marginal probability of taking the value
true
inside this cluster here
so now because the cluster volumes get
quite big we suddenly get these
funny long-range correlations however
um again according to our good friends
from physics there's
a way out namely if instead of
looking at random satisfying assignments
we look at these
encodings of clusters these zero one
star encodings
then we basically disregard the cluster
volumes themselves
and um our physics friends predict that
if you look at these encodings then you
still have this decorrelation property
then still
variables that are far apart from one
another
are going to be independent so if i
forget about satisfying assignments and
say
i don't care about when what a random
satisfying assignment is
i care about what this zero one star
encoding of a random cluster of
satisfying assignments does if i choose
one of these clusters uniformly at
random
then suddenly i can expect to recover
this
correlation decay condition according to
our friends from physics
so now um that's that's wonderful news
but what do we make of it how do we
use that information and so one one idea
that you could now pursue is you could
try and use this information to count
satisfying assignments
and specifically if we assume that
there's no long-range correlations
between variables then we could look at
the following process we start
with n variables and no clauses
whatsoever
and now we add clauses one by one
and for each clause we inspect
the number of satisfying
assignments of the formula without that
clause
that do not survive the addition of this
one clause
so in other words we look at the
probability
that this clause wipes out a
random satisfying assignment of the
previous formula of the previous
structure that we had and because our
clauses are random
the attachment points of the new clause
that that comes along that is dropped
down on us
um are going to be far apart typically
so
if i'm assuming that there's no
long-range correlations then i can say
well
the probability that this guy here said
to true is something and
the probability that this guy is set to
true is something and the probability
that that guy is set to true is
something
but they are going to be independent so
if i want to calculate the probability
that um a random satisfying assignment
of my of this of this box formula down
here survives the new clause
then this probability factorizes and
therefore all i need to control
is i just need to control the marginal
probabilities that these
that a bunch that that a random variable
really
in my formula is set to true
so i just need to compute i just need to
get a handle on on these marginal
probabilities
um what's the probability that a
specific variable
takes the value true under a random
satisfying assignment
and once i get a handle on that i could
then try and analyze this process
try and trace this process and compute
the number of satisfying assignments
that my random formula will contain in
the end
and so the idea behind
and of course in general computing these
marginal probabilities is again
an intractable problem but
we can try and bootstrap on this idea of
local independence again
and this is what belief propagation does
so belief propagation
is based on the assumption that you
don't have long range correlations in
your system in your formula in your
random formula
and um therefore we can play the
following trick
so we want to look at this process of
attaching clauses
like this one here and therefore we need
to be
able to understand the marginal
probability that this variable here
takes a particular value like for
example true
in the absence of this clause here so
after i remove the clause i want to know
the probability that this guy here is
set to true under a random
satisfying assignment and
so let's give this quantity this
probability that x is set to true
in the formula where i delete clause a
let's give that a name
and let's call that the belief
propagation message from
x to a then
under the hypothesis that there's no
long-range correlations
we can write down a system of equations
that these messages should satisfy
specifically suppose i want to express
the message from x to a the probability
that x is set to true
after i delete clause a from my formula
suppose i want to express that in terms
of the messages
that these variables down here these
four variables to the left and to the
right of x send
to the other clauses in which x
appears then what i can
hypothesize so if i put on my
physicist's head what i can hypothesize
is well um suppose i remove not just a
but also b1 and b2 from my formula
then because everything is random most
likely
these four variables down here are going
to be far apart from one another
and therefore there are joint marginals
the probability that they jointly take
some particular
combination of truth values is going to
factorize is going to turn into a
product measure
and therefore the probability that
x takes some particular value in the
absence of a
can actually be expressed nicely by a
sum
product formula product because of
independence
in terms of the messages that these
variables down here sent
to the clauses b1 and b2
now that's quite a bit of stuff i mean
that's quite a mouthful right
and it's not so easy to actually
formalize this and to write down the
formulas
for this process that you would expect
to get it's not rocket science either
but it's not something you do in five
minutes anyway so if you
if you pursue this idea if you pursue
this idea that there's no long-range
correlations and that these
these um child variables these four
variables here to the left and to the
right
are far apart once i remove ab1 and b2
from my formula
then you get a set of equations that
that relate the
messages to one another and
these equations that you get are called
the belief propagation equations
and these equations are written down
here in a very compact notation
i don't expect you to to grasp them
completely of course if you haven't seen
them before
but just to give you an idea what they
look like
so under the under the assumption of
absence of long-range correlations we
can reasonably write down
these recurrence relations here that
express the messages so again the
message from x to a
is the probability that variable x is
set to true
under a random satisfying assignment
of the formula where i delete clause a
so i first delete clause a then i look
at the remaining formula sample random
satisfying assignment
and look at the probability that this
assignment is going to set x to one
it's a bit complicated but not that
complicated maybe
these equations i mean deriving these
equations is not entirely
straightforward but
my point is that you can actually write
down a system of equations
that is self-contained and that relates
these messages to one another
and if we assume that um the true
messages are actually
a solution to the set of equations then
maybe we are in luck and maybe these
equations only have a single solution
or maybe they only have a single
dominant solution or maybe only a single
attractive solution
and so we could try and start somewhere
for example
at the point varies where we initialize
all the messages with one
and we could perform some kind of a
fixed point iteration on these equations
down here
in order to find a solution to the
system of equations
and that is exactly what the belief
propagation
message passing algorithm does
now how about survey propagation so
survey propagation
always works with these generalized
satisfying assignments that are these
zero one star
encodings of clusters and
the details are a bit more complicated
but the basic
intuition is the same so again we define
messages where we say
well okay i'm going to look at the
probability
that in a random cluster of solutions
some particular variable is either
frozen to 0
to false or frozen to true or unfrozen
after i remove some particular clause
and then i set up
a system of equation a kind of self
consistent system of equations for these
messages i start at some initialization
some cleverly or maybe not so cleverly
chosen
initialization i perform a fixed point
iteration
and then hopefully maybe with a bit of
luck i'm going to converge
to the correct solution
to these fixed point equations so i mean
there's a lot of ifs there of course and
a lot of question marks
and um so maybe it's not a surprise that
it took quite a long time to
sort the details out
[Music]
but well i mean it's if you i mean it's
an acquired taste but
once you get into it it makes it makes
some sense
in particular if you grind these
equations for long enough you get
you can squeeze out of survey
propagation a prediction as to the
precise value of your satisfiability
threshold
unsurprisingly this formula involves
the survey propagation messages and
because these method messages actually
vary from one variable to the other so
depending on the local geometry
of the formula around some particular
variable some variables have
i mean the different variables are going
to have
are going to emit different messages
the right mathematical abstraction of
these messages
is a probability distribution
a probability distribution that tells
you what's the probability that a
randomly chosen variable in my
formula is frozen to true for example
and this conjecture the survey
propagation conjecture for the
satisfiability threshold comes as a
variational problem
that asks you to find this distribution
of messages pi
that minimizes a certain functional
and this functional never mind the
details actually comes out of this
process
that i described earlier where you
attach one clause at a time and
look at the probability that a random
cluster of solutions
to your previous formula survives
this attachment process so it's it's not
entirely straightforward it's not not
trivial but
there's some combinatorial meaning
behind it namely you trace this
attachment process
and if you if you stare at it long
enough and if you sit down and do the
calculations you get these beautiful
formulas down here
that involves a lot of randomness
it's maybe surprising that for a problem
that is easy to describe like kasat you
end up with the formula like this but
you do
and the good news about this is that
this is self-contained
so you end up with an optimization
problem on the space of probability
measures
the problem is in closed form it's
self-contained
you don't need to know anything about
satisfiability to think about this
problem
so it's an analytic problem that you can
look at and
maybe eventually solve
so of course i mean this this was quite
something at the time and
people said about proving these physics
conjectures and attempting to develop
rigorous methods to
get to grips with them and one of the
techniques that was developed and that
has by now been
or become one of the mainstays of
probabilistic combinatorics i would say
is the interpolation method um this is
an idea that that we borrowed from spin
glass
theory it was transformed into
satisfiability problems by
franz and leone and ponchenko and
telegram
and this method is it's a bit
it looks a bit like cheating if you see
it first but
it's it actually works this method is
a very much enhanced version of the
first moment method
i don't have the time to explain it in
much detail but
you can in many contexts in
combinatorics where you use the first
movement method you can actually get
better bounce out of the interpolation
method and the interpolation method like
the first moment method gives you an
upper bound on the satisfiability
threshold and
can be used to deduce that
whatever crazy expression the physicists
obtained using their ideas
at least gives an upper bound on the
satisfiability threshold
that's wonderful news how about a lower
bound well for the lower bound
there was a development that started
about the same time
at the sd physics ideas started to
emerge
based on a non-constructive argument the
second moment method
and this was a pioneered by aclioptus
and moore in 2002 where they
counted particular solutions to random
formulas called
motor equal solutions and culminated
in a truly monumental paper by dingsly
and sun in 2014
where they managed to prove the matching
lower bound
mainly they managed to prove that this
that this survey propagation prediction
predicted actually
yields the correct satisfiability
threshold
however in contrast to the
old arguments the old lower bounds
all of these lower bounds are
non-constructive they are not based on
algorithms
so um how about algorithms
so how can we actually try and uh
construct solutions to random formulas
well one idea that you could pursue is
something called the decimation process
so imagine that we have a magical oracle
that for a given set formula tells us
the marginal probability that a
particular variable
is set to true under a random satisfying
assignment
then we could actually use this oracle
to sample
a satisfying assignment randomly how do
we do that well we go over the variables
one by one
we ask the oracle what's the marginal
probability that the first guy is set to
true
and with exactly that probability we
actually set
that variable to true we pursue the
obvious implications of that decision
like for example we eliminate the
clauses where the variable appears
positively and we remove the variable
from all the clauses that appears
negatively
and then we go back to our oracle and
ask about the second variable
now in this reduced formula so we asked
the oracle in this reduced formula
what's the probability that the second
guy is set to true
we set that variable to true with the
corresponding probability and so on
until we are done until we are through
and
found a satisfying assignment and it's
easy to see using bayes rule that
the result of this process is actually
going to be a random
solution to your formula
now of course we don't have such an
oracle at hand because
computing these marginals is a number p
hard problem
but in place of this magical oracle we
could actually try and use
belief propagation guided decimal we
could actually try and use belief
propagation
this funny idea of conducting this fixed
point iteration on our random formula
so we would launch this fixed point
iteration
run it until we get tired and then hope
that maybe
on the basis of these belief propagation
messages we can actually estimate
the probability that a specific variable
is set to true and
substitute this oracle into the
decimation process so
that's one idea another idea
is to apply the same strategy not to
satisfying assignments themselves but
to these zero one star representations
of
clusters of satisfying assignments so
never mind counting satisfying
assignments let's
go let's let's go for an entire cluster
of satisfying assignments so let's first
try and
see who is frozen to true or to false
and who is unfrozen
and once we've done that we could then
try and apply i mean
starting from the 0 1 star vector we
could launch a local search algorithm
for example
and try to find a satisfying assignment
in that way
and that's the strategy behind the
survey propagation guided decimation
algorithm so we
again use this message passing
these message passing equations this
fixed point iteration in order to find
the survey propagation messages then we
compute on the basis of these messages
the marginal probabilities that a
specific variable is
frozen to true or false or unfrozen
decimate accordingly according to this
marginal probability and iterate
and ultimately we use a local search
algorithm
and that is exactly what these
physics-based
algorithms do like um the simple
there's a very simple version of a
vanilla version of belief propagation
here
these are versions of belief and survey
propagation that
are slightly enhanced that use some
heuristic
decisions on top of the processes that i
just described
in any case so the question now of
course arises whether we can actually
analyze these algorithms can we actually
understand where these numbers in this
little diagram here come from
and can we maybe either prove or
disprove that these algorithms will
succeed that they will be any good and
so again the physicist led the way and
in a paper by
uh richie tasenki and semajan in 2009
um an analysis appeared a heuristic
analysis of these algorithms appeared
that
predicted that the leaf propagation
guided decimation
will work up to a particular clause
variable ratio
e times 2 to the k on k
that looks a little bit less fantastic
than these
experimental results appear
and of course this analysis was
heuristic so
we attempted to turn it into a theorem
and we
so yeah at first i succeeded on belief
propagation
and to the extent that i managed to show
that belief propagation
is going to fail this belief propagation
guided decimation algorithm is going to
fail
once your clause to variable ratio
exceeds some constant times two to the k
on k so up to the value of the constant
which
according to this is e
this verified the prediction
and the problem is easy to describe the
problem that belief propagation guided
decimation runs into is simply that
the decimation process itself
adds constraints to the problem so as
you assign values
one after the other to the variables you
effectively add constraints to your
problem
and the constraints that you add are
going to precipitate
long-range correlations
so this process of setting one variable
at a time has the same effect in other
words
as adding more clauses to your to your
formula and therefore um
so that's the trap that belief
propagation effectively runs into
and a little later a student of mine
samuel hederick
proved that survey propagation actually
runs
into the same trap and that also this
algorithm is going to
stall well below the satisfiability
threshold actually almost a factor of k
below the satisfiability threshold which
as you remember
is approximately 2 to the k times log 2.
so yeah that's bad news for belief and
survey propagation
um and also
by the time we already had another
combinatorial algorithm
that actually outperforms i belief
propagation guided decimation
and matches at least for large k the
performance of
survey propagation guided decimation
so finally let's talk let's come back to
random twoset which was the first
problem that
we managed to understand mathematically
and
let's see what belief propagation does
on random two-side formulas
so we can ask if we look at a random
two-sided formula
below the satisfiability threshold so
number of clauses is less than number of
variables
what is the number of satisfying
assignments and that question actually
was first raised
in a paper by fernandez de la viga in
2001 as far as i know
and um even though a two-set
finding a solution to a two-sided
problem is an easy problem
turns out that calculating the number of
solutions is
actually hard it's number p hard so it's
uh yeah it's an intractable problem in
the worst case
so can we solve this problem on random
formulas maybe using
belief propagation and um
in fact it turns out that
elementary techniques like the first
moment method
or other elementary ideas based on
percolation will fail
so the problem is not as easy as
one might at first glance expect um
anyhow so recently uh in collaboration
with demetrius acklyopters
and my students maxine kimhort
june lee
and yeah manuel penchuk
and collaborator
jin zhu from china we managed to
um we managed to solve this problem
and what we what we proved was that um
actually belief propagation for the
random two sub problem
does provide you with the correct
marginals and does provide you
with the correct number of um satisfying
assignments
um the difference is is a bit subtle so
this dotted line the started blue line
here is what the first moment method
would get you
and the red line is um what belief
propagation gives you and what the
the true answer is in terms of the
density of clauses to variables
the difference might look small but it's
on an exponent it's on a logarithmic
scale so
the difference is actually exponential
in n
so just to wrap up belief propagation
and survey propagation
are very powerful combinatorial and also
algorithmic ideas
however it actually seems in hindsight
that solving satisfiability instances
is maybe not their strong suit so
these algorithms have turned out to be
extremely useful
in other areas like for example in error
correcting codes and decoding
or in compressed sensing and some other
applications but
it seems that maybe satisfiability is
not
the strongest application that springs
to mind
at the same time quite a lot about their
performance still remains unknown so for
example
to this day we have no idea where these
numbers come from
and yeah what combinatorial phenomena
are the work and explain why these
algorithms work precisely up to these
values um one thing that i don't know
and that i would be curious to
find out is whether this idea of looking
at generalized satisfying assignments
like these zero one star assignments
actually appears
in set solving that and maybe has any
any uses
in uh practical set solving as well so
yeah at this point i'll stop thanks for
your attention and sorry for going a
little bit over time
some i think you're mute some
let me try that again i was thanking you
very much for very nice talk
and encouraging everyone to join me
while i clapped
since they can't clap themselves and uh
thank you for unmuting me albert
um so i guess now we enter the
discussion section session there was a
another question in the chat window and
also a q a
question um why don't we take them in
the order that they came in the q
a was sam maguire asked
can we estimate the number of clusters
above 2 to the k
log k over k yes
yes that was from earlier in your talk
that's a very good question
um so that's a very good question so
the basic idea would be to actually use
survey propagation to estimate the
number of clusters
the number of clusters has a name in
statistical physics
it's called i mean of all things it's
called the complexity of the
satisfiability problem
and so there is a heuristic formula that
tells you
how you get from the survey propagation
fixed point that you calculate to the
number of clusters
however it is very unclear
whether this formula works for all
for all densities above this magical 2
to the k log k on k
threshold and that is because
of of a very subtle phenomenon
called full replica symmetry breaking
that that may
be present in this regime the short
answer is
it's an excellent question um we don't
know
okay good let's see paul beam has a
question in the chat window
and i and oh paul paul did this already
but let me just remind you
when you post a question to the chat
window please direct it to all
panelists and attendees so that everyone
can see it by default just goes to the
panelists
um so paul's question is
what are the type downs for the ksat
threshold
that come out of survey propagation
optimization
yeah exactly um so that's another
excellent question
if only i could find this light
right so um i mean this slide here
gives you the formulas and all that
glory
and um so
yeah and so what you would have to do is
you would have to find
the inf of this beautiful functional
here
over the space of all probability
measures on the unit interval
now that's quite a tall order because
that's quite a large space
in fact it's an infinite dimensional
space
and and you would have to sift through
it somehow in order to find
and optimize this function over that
space in order to find the true answer
so of course that's that's completely
infeasible and for example for
k equals three or four um that's the
only answer that i can give i can i can
i can say that well um
based on the axioms for the real numbers
i can promise you that this infimum is a
well-defined
real number uh good luck computing it
now that's not very satisfactory and it
turns out that for
large values of k there's something
better that you can do
so for the values of k that are in the
ding slice some for
which the ding slice sun argument works
this theorem that verifies this
satisfiability threshold conjecture or
large k
for the values where that works um what
you can do is actually something
algorithmic
in that case what you can do is you can
find you can perform this fixed point
iteration on
satisfiability formulas induced by
golden watson trees
and if you do that for a large enough
height
of the corresponding tree then you can
find
a a distribution that approximates this
in within any given accuracy
so there's an algorithmic there's a
mechanical way of doing it of getting
numbers out of it but it only works for
large k and unfortunately nobody knows
what large k
means here and i'm guessing large means
really really large i mean so largely
you don't want to meet this number
particularly at night
so uh it's uh it's um
not a practical answer either in physics
of course what people do is they start a
heuristic fixed point iteration
at some distribution using an algorithm
called population
dynamics and they cross their fingers
that maybe they are in luck and they
find the correct minimizer and to be
honest they probably are
um right so there's no there's no simple
formula for this
there's an approximation that one can
get and the approximation i think it was
on one of these slides
maybe hopefully maybe not
so the approximation that you can get is
that the answer is quite close to the
first moment upper bound
uh exactly this is quite close to the
first movement
okay okay i think i lost the chat a
little bit
so the next question was from oliver
colt coleman uh
third from the last he's referring back
to something you mentioned the beginning
of the talk some intuitive explanation
on those differential equations would be
great
right yeah it's not difficult actually
um so these differential equations
uh are they here um they actually just
so they just describe um the following
things so y
three is supposed to be
the density of clauses of length three
as you run unit clause
propagation so i mean you
obviously are very familiar with unit
clause propagation
and what happens in unit cross
propagation is that you start with a
preset problem
but then some of the clauses get shorter
and obviously once you produce a lot of
clauses of degree one
you get yourself into some serious
trouble because at that point you're
bound to
[Music]
bound to run into contradictions
so you want to kind of you want to
track clauses of length two and
three and cross your fingers that you
don't
with any positive probability ever
construct clauses of length one
um and so y three and y two are the
densities of clauses of length two and
three respectively
and these equations basically express
the flow
of equations of layer of
clauses of length 3 into clauses of
length 2
and of course the flow of clauses of
length two that you just satisfy
um so that's basically what this does
and t is
the fraction of variables that you set
that you have set already
[Music]
so it's yeah and you can actually solve
this equation
uh analytically it has an explicit
equation for
k equals three and if you run
experiments you see that
it's and you can also prove this of
course
asymptotically for an arch n but if you
run experiments then you see that this
differential equation approximation is
spot on for unit clause
and the x what is the uh x
sorry the x is supposed to be a t
just just to clarify this means the flow
as you're
doing unit propagation that is right
okay
okay okay all right
okay um ryan williams has a question in
the window
uh i'll read it out for what clause
densities can believe propagation
approximate
uh counting to sat in polynomial time
question mark all constant clause
density is less than one
what does the detection head assignments
look like yeah
that is exactly what we get
so uh exactly so for it works for all
densities below 1.
it's a bit unsurprising that it works
for densities below a half
because in that case your random
two-sided formula
decomposes into tiny little components
tiny little
isolated sub formulas
for densities less than a half but for
densities
up to one or for densities above a half
it's actually not easy because in that
case what happens is that
a giant component a huge connected
component of
clauses and variables appears and
quickly
fills up most of the or quickly swallows
up most of the
formulas and clauses and what this
result here shows is that in fact for
all
densities right up to the satisfiability
threshold belief propagation gives you
the right answer
and um so again the answer doesn't come
i mean we are not entitled i'm afraid to
a
neat little
neat little simple formula but
the answer simply comes in terms of
belief propagation so
i could again write a variational
problem and and drop that on you and
tell you well here's here's an in
over a set of over the space of all
probability measures on zero one good
luck finding it
um but also in this case we actually
have a guarantee that using
three approximations using effectively
finite
[Music]
finite number of rounds of population
dynamics
you will get within any given accuracy
of
the given or of the true answer and so
again this red line here is the limit of
one on n
expectation log number of satisfying
assignments
for any density between zero and
[Music]
any any clause variable density between
zero and one this is actually
parametrized in terms of twice the
number of clauses on n in terms of the
average variable degree
that's why this plot here ends only at
2.
and this left this left picture here
shows
the empirical distribution of messages
that you get for various densities
so these various lines here like for
example this blue dotted line and the
red line and the black line
are the cdfs of the distribution of
messages
for various clause to variable densities
and if you look at this for a little bit
you see that
the distribution is symmetric which is
unsurprising because
in this random formula every variable or
the the
the signs of the literals are chosen
randomly so you would expect
a symmetric cdf in the ensometric around
a half
but what you also see is that there's no
particularly
simple pattern emerging i mean you see a
few
jumps in this function in the cdf and
these come
from peculiar tree formulas little
components in your
entire two-side formula
but apart from that we expect that what
you see here is
a mixture of a continuous and a discrete
distribution
thank you okay
um albert serious has a
comment the question here so i'll read
it out some concepts like satisfiability
threshold of course are particular
of random formulas but the concept of of
correlation decay and it's used for
algorithms could well apply to worst
case instances with similar parameters
say density or hereditary density
any chance worst case analysis could be
done
that's a good question so i think that's
an excellent question it would be
interesting to maybe study this also
um in the context of ideas such as the
lova's local lemma
maybe i mean there has been some work in
this direction
um already of course
uh like for example muy trustwork but
i i think it would be very interesting
to uh to look into this i mean there has
been extensive work for example in the
context of the
hardcore model and other other spin
models
where this connection between something
like gibbs uniqueness and
complexity has been analyzed but
yeah all i know there's quite a bit of
um
yeah there's there's quite a number of
white spots on the map
when it comes to satisfiability
yeah exactly and albert adds that that's
the worst case
it should be emphasized yeah yeah
exactly so i i think it's very
interesting
the other question i don't know about is
to what extent the sub solving community
um has actually been interested in
or has been looking into algorithms for
counting or sampling satisfying
assignments i mean
i know there's this great body of work
on clause learning and so on about
finding satisfying assignments but i
don't know if there's been any
um similar extent of research on let's
say
sampling of or counting solutions
yeah exactly this sort of yeah i don't
know anything about that so
i i would be i should really learn about
this because
i mean this this work on random sub is
much more
of the uh counting and sampling flavor
in some sense than of the uh
finding uh so
so uh paul um so one one quick comment
so
uh those in the program so uh there's
work by
uh called neil and others uh on
on actually trying to find uh to
approximate the number of solutions
we did some some work earlier on uh
finding uh trying to do exact counts
um they're difficult with standard
uh you know cdcl extensions even
of cdcl type solvers that try to break
if you want to do things exactly that
break things into components you can
save some things there but they start to
fail for the same reasons that
uh sat solvers fail on on on random
formulas so
they end up being quite difficult and i
don't know whether the approximate
uh solutions you know for sorry the
random formula instance is how they
behave with respect to model counting
that's very interesting yeah yeah i
should look into that
i i don't know enough enough about this
i'm afraid so yeah it would be very uh
yeah i i'm i'm not sure that they work
very well
in in those contexts might be able to uh
to uh would be certainly want to talk to
about
about that okay
yep thomas cockman
mentioned something related on slide 12
of a hidden of a possible hidden
bayesian thought
connections to bayesian networks yeah
one challenge i have with slide 12
is that i can't actually get that
quickly because somehow
page up and page down doesn't work while
i'm sharing the screen
so yeah i'll get here eventually
yeah exactly i mean of course this is
very closely related to bayesian
networks
where again belief propagation is uh
is kind of one of the uh killer
algorithms i guess
um it's it's actually um
yes so that's one thing and also it's
it's related to the fact that these
random
k-set formulas um don't contain
so if you look at this clause variable
incidence graph
they don't contain a huge number of
short cycles
so locally they essentially look like
trees which means that
belief propagation which excels on um
acyclic bayesian networks works so
so well on them
yeah exactly so what exactly what what
if we add a third dimension so that's a
very good point
um so of course this is um
[Music]
i mean this is sort of the the original
idea or the original
dimension that physicists would have in
mind
so normally from a statistical physics
viewpoint what you would do is you would
actually
fix the geometry of your problem you
would fix
m and n and you would play with another
parameter called
inverse temperature that effectively
scans through
the various qualities of assignments so
how many
clauses you uh or how many clauses you
you satisfy or fail to satisfy
and that would give you another
dimension and that that is exactly what
normally people would study in the spin
glass community
and what you see is uh
what you see is of course if you if you
kind of look at that
parameter as well you get a
two-dimensional phase diagram where you
have
um the clause variable density on one
axis and
beta the inverse temperature the quality
of the solutions on the other axis
and what you discover of course is that
i mean in this phase here nothing
interesting happens if you
relax the problem if you are willing to
compromise and leave a few clauses
unsatisfied
but here and here what happens is that
you as you as you
um increase the temperature as you are
willing to
leave more and more clauses violated you
will see
that you effectively move left in the
space diagram
so here in this picture once you make
your your temperature large enough or
your inverse temperature is more
small enough you will recover the left
picture
okay uh
su super t posted just the panelists let
me read it out to the
everyone regarding paul's comment indeed
for approximate counting sampling
techniques
random c formulas pose the same problems
um jacob nordstrom's ask a question uh
to everyone
you wanna my understanding is that there
are ai applications for uniformly
sampling random satisfying assignments
to a formula
and that there's some some some
literature on this
some rigorous some not so much
they weren't having to apply that yeah
if you really look into this i mean this
is uh yeah
would be interesting to i mean i'm
wondering if any mileage can be
uh can be got out of this idea of
counting clusters or relaxing the
problem in some
coming up with some combinatorial
relaxation but maybe this
is being done already i just don't know
much about this on this right
so if i could ask a rather simple
question
just to make sure my understanding is
okay you mentioned the icing models were
the
were the inspiration for a lot of this
and the connection here is just that the
icing
spin models are very local you look at
spins of adjacent
um atoms and likewise in random ksat
we're looking at
a local connections between clauses is
that is that
is that the connection or is there
something else i'm not seeing right i
mean so the
um so the easing model is um
i mean so at first glance is or i mean
so the easing model by itself is
actually quite a lot simpler than these
these random k-sub models
and the reason is that let's say in the
ferromagnetic version of the easing
model
there's a simple ground state there's a
simple way of satisfying
all the constraints and that is you just
polarize
all your magnetic spins in one direction
for example the all plus one solution
is the ultimate configuration in your
easing model
everybody is happy as happy as they can
ever be
and so
so because there's this kind of obvious
ground state this obvious solution
the problem is conceptually easier
there's something else
called the sharing kirkpatrick model or
the edwards anderson model
and that is an easing model where
instead of having
ferromagnetic interactions instead of
the situation where everybody
wants to be in agreement you put an
interaction term between two atoms that
is random
and so this interaction term is
sometimes ferromagnetic
sometimes the two atoms that are
interacting for example
on a grid or on a on a complete graph
want to be in agreement and sometimes
they want to disagree
and with this random interaction
you suddenly get a structure that i mean
this is called the edwards anderson
model
and in this version of the easing model
you get something that is very similar
to the k-sub model there are some
where you are in this situation that a
variable
is dragged in two different directions
by its adjacent clauses it appears
positively in some of the clauses and
negatively in some others
so some of the clauses go to that
variable and say please be
true and some others tell the variable
please take the value false
so the variable is tracked in two
directions there's no obvious ground
state
i mean if i present you with a randomly
chosen case that
problem there's unlike in the easings
case
no way of saying okay i'm just doing
this and everybody is happy
and so this this thing that you are that
everybody
is subject to influences or
pressure in two different direction that
is the common feature
good and another question too if i can
be committed two of them
your uh that your your decimation
process
looks a little bit like the ppsz
algorithm for
sad satisfiability except there you
don't use probable probabilities i was
just wondering maybe it's a question for
you or the audience is there any
connection between those two has anyone
looked at those
in a common setting for the audience
okay
yeah so the the ppsc algorithm works by
setting variables one at a time and
either if a variable is forced setting
it true or false
and otherwise setting it to a value with
probability one-half
and sort of hoping for the best whereas
you had some algorithm that set things
according to probabilities
based on some marginal probability
calculation so i'm just wondering if
there's any known known connection
between these two
i'll things that as a note i guess
uh any further questions
so uh i i don't know whether it's a
question yes i guess it's
it's a question in terms of the the
models for spin glasses you know you're
used to thinking we're used to thinking
them
in sort of fixed dimensions two
dimensions three dimensions
uh i mean especially three dimensions
being uh particularly interesting
my recollection and i wanna i'm trying
to get it is that
things for um for a case that were
closer to like
infinite carry trees or something like
that i'm trying to try it
but i'm trying to recover that whether
that's accurate or
whether or there's some other um type of
structure that's sort of
the natural analog of that one we should
think about in that context
there's a bit of history behind this um
so
i mean the first spin glass model out
there as far as i know was the edwards
anderson model in a grid or
in a three-dimensional space but
unfortunately
even physicists don't have the foggiest
how to solve them
or what to say about them and in fact in
physics there's there's
a different slants on the glass problem
which is quite related
so this is about how
silicon and oxygen actually form a glass
as you
as you cool them down as you anneal them
and there's different
schools in physics that have different
opinions how this happens and what the
correct physical explanation is
there's parisi and his replica symmetry
breaking
slant and there's other ideas
and i i think this is a wonderful
argument to stay out of as a
mathematician
and so in order to make things a bit
easier
what happened is that physicists started
to investigate models on a complete
graph
so i don't know if you if you know the
query vice model which is kind of the
complete graph version of the easing
model so that's a model that you can
teach in class
in about an hour and you can solve it
completely and it's wonderful
and you learn a lot and in a similar
fashion there's
a version of this edwards anderson model
that lives on a complete graph
where any two atoms any two sites
interact but they interact weakly
and this model is called the scherring
kirkpatrick model
and that's in on the mathematical side
on the probability theory side of spin
glass theory that's the holy grail
everybody wants to understand the sharon
kirkpatrick model there was a
breakthrough paper by
tyler grant in 2006 there was a
follow-up
breakthrough work by ponchenko on
something called the ultrametricity
conjecture
so um that's basically a a model that is
a huge simplification of the edwards
anderson model
now in physics people then try to go
back once they heuristically once parisi
heuristically
and later mathematically telegram and
others
understand understood the model they
went back and said well let's try and
find
a halfway point between the geometric
model and
the sharing kirkpatrick model on the
complete graph the edwards anderson and
the sk model
and what they came up with was something
called the vjana bray model
and that is basically the edwards
anderson model on
a sparse random graph on a for example
on a random d regular graph or on an
arduiny random graph
and this model was studied in 2000 2001
by mizar and parisi they made some
progress
and that is how they got into random
satisfiability
because that model is conceptually and
they have things like survey propagation
and belief propagation and all that
stuff already set up for that model
and that model is is hugely similar to
random satisfiability and random graph
coloring and you name it
thanks
very good any other discussion or
questions
all right well thank you again for a
very stimulating talk uh
that seems like people are very
interested lots of discussion so thank
you so much
uh so otherwise we're done so thank you
thank you
um all right enjoy the rest of your day
yes everyone else too all right good
okay bye